The plane is stuck.
It's a little stuck.
-Wow.
-Wow. Oh, my God.
-Holy shit.
-We're on an adventure.
Welcome to the Maasai Mara.
OK. Now it's sunny.
And we're here, and it's so beautiful.
I can't understand it.
Zebra!
Oh, I love that thing.
I really never thought
I'd get a chance to come over here.
You know, you see pictures,
and you never know actually,
what it really looks like
or how it really feels.
And it just feels like
how it's supposed to be.
Look, over there! Look, back, back!
He's right there!
Like how it's been forever.
Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
I'm so sorry. Sorry, sorry.
I've never seen an elephant in real life.
There's four!
A baby!
Oh, my gosh.
It keeps getting crazier!
I don't know if I've ever seen
anything so beautiful.
This is insane.
And apparently there was a lion
next to my room last night.
Really rude,
didn't even come say hi to me.
If she wants to, you are her breakfast.
It's really interesting to see
a specialized predator
like a cheetah in this space.
You get a better understanding
of why they need this much space.
Why they need such a vast,
expansive land to exist.
So, we have to walk
in a single file line.
And if anything happens...
you don't run.
Look at that big one.
Oh, my God.
You OK?
My hands are shaking.
OK, I've been told
I have to calm down, so, I am.
I've now...
had a panic attack and cried.
But I feel like I'm in
a better place now, right?
You guys, it's happening.
I think I'll need
two gin and tonics tonight.
Nine lions just passed by so close
that my iPhone wouldn't
shoot on portrait mode.
That's how close they were.
Yep.
Cheers.
In my time here, the last three days,
I have seen lots of elephants, giraffes
baby... lions, zebras...
Which I guess are pronounced zeb-ras.
Who knew?
I have seen a lot more
than I ever thought
I'd see in my whole life.
And to me, what struck me the most,
is how beautiful and big this land is.
And how fragile it is.
It's just spectacular.
The people... are spectacular.
The culture is spectacular,
the animals are, of course, spectacular.
She's so beautiful.
There is a future and hope for
a world in which animals, wildlife,
humans, can coexist peacefully.
Oh, they're so amazing.
But being here and seeing first-hand,
it becomes that much more clear
that if we continue
to care and love and nurture...
there is hope.
We just have to stay on that path.